what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay so getting back into uh fear itself
again this is just one of those kind of
transitionary stories but for thor
it's actually pretty interesting fear
itself kind of goes into
a sort of reshuffling of the landscape
for the thor miss mythos somewhat of a
change-up and again that even goes into
uh
really the new mighty thor run with with
tanneris and focuses on like the
rebuilding of asgard the formation of
asgardia but at the moment we're
basically picking up with like the fall
of thor not in the sense that he died
but in the sense that thor had basically
been defeated or at least fought to the
point of exhaustion facing off against
uh the combined efforts of ben grimm the
thing and the incredible hulk both of
whom had the power of
thor essentially and it was cool you
know to see that whole thing take place
but it means that even thor has limits
and so in response to this the idea is
earth cannot treat thor
earth cannot basically give him the
medicine he needs in order to survive
and so they have to take him to asgard
in order to
get him the kind of treatment that he
needs but again with captain america
showing up here
this is actually pretty badass because
you've got heimdall who kind of who
tells odin look like
there are people showing up here and
captain america alongside like hawkeye
and a handful of others end up bringing
in
thor's body and then captain america
proceeds to read odin the riot act do he
do he
he rips him up and down he's like thor
fix him this moment right now and i
don't want to hear any of this stuff
about midgard has to die i don't want to
hear any of your nonsense
fix him and be done with it and odin's
just kind of like left
stammering right you know odin
is not used to being so openly defied
especially by like an earthling but
that's the nature of captain america
captain america is not really special
there's really nothing unique about him
aside from his shield but what he lacks
in basically anything that makes a
superhero worthwhile in terms of powers
he gains in terms of his willingness to
basically
do whatever it takes to win but walking
into asgard
and then smack talking odin and telling
him do your damn job is something you
don't normally see and it's cool because
odin just kind of whisks them away right
off the bat now
you know reading between the lines here
we could probably make an argument that
there's some respect from odin
to captain america the guy's got courage
and the guys got like
honor and duty and these are things that
you don't readily find out there and so
it's kind of cool
because it's one of these things where
odin could just incinerate him just wipe
out the entirety of the avengers but
instead just sends them back to earth
now in reality this is done because the
plot has to move forward i mean that's
really the reason why it happened
the issue with this is that there really
is no one left you know they're
basically in a boat this
again very akin to age of ultron where
it's like so there's like
there's like five of us here and we're
basically the last men standing there
there's there's really no one else here
that can save us now
in response to this with thor basically
receiving the kind of treatment he needs
in order to recover odin is essentially
forced to acquiesce or at least
temporarily to basically say
you were right and i was wrong you know
earth has mighty heroes and if you
really feel the need to fight alongside
them if you really believe this is
something that you have to do
then do it then take my armor with it
and so basically
thor gets odin's odin's armor and it's
one of these things where odin says look
i wore this armor when i fought the
serpent and defeated him the first time
this armor will help you now
it is formidable in its own right it
does enhance the powers of thor to a
degree
but it's really more of like a
protection spell basically meaning like
the the full
bright and you know the full might and
brunt of the serpent won't affect you
in the same way it did if you didn't
have this armor in the first place but
notice this where thor is ready to sort
of be brash and run
headlong there's something to be said
about odin basically saying look you
believe you're ready but you're not
because you're seeing this as a young
man you don't have the years or
the wisdom to understand that what
you're basically doing is going headlong
into a losing battle it's the prophecy's
been foretold you're going to die here
now something else that i want you guys
to take note of here is that this
prophecy that odin
is referring to is the prophecy of the
midgard serpent now the midgard serpent
is totally different from this version
of the serpent
they're distinctly different beings or
at least in the original intention in
which they were made when it comes to
the midgard serpent
in an actual norse mythology the idea
was that in the
in the battle of ragnarok the midgard
serpent would pierce thor with a poison
tooth and it would kill him and so when
jack kirby grabbed those things and
rolled it over
the idea was that thor would basically
die during the events of ragnarok facing
off against the midgard serpent what
marvel's really doing here is they're
sort of cooking the books
really if we're being honest with
ourselves what marvel's doing is they're
saying well the midgard serpent was
believed to be
you know believed to have been you know
your your oh god how do you how do you
pronounce that you're among
your mungender i think it is i'm not
really sure how to pronounce that but
like the midgar serpent you know is
is this thing that's there but in
reality it's actually the hidden brother
of odin that's kind of what they're
saying
but the other half of this is that thor
actually also gets the odin sword and
the odin sword is a pretty
powerful artifact i mean this is one of
the few things out there
that is really beyond reproach when it
comes to insane levels of power now
historically speaking in marvel comics
the odin sword has kind of been like a
multi-faceted object meaning there have
been multiple weapons out there that
have been dubbed as the
as the the odin sword if you look at
like thor number 300 for example when
thor fights the celestials and and
just becomes like ridiculously op at one
point there's an instance where he's
wielding what's called the over sword
which is kind of like the ultimate
weapon out there created by odin
and then of course you have like this as
the actual odin sword in reality
it kind of fluctuates depending on what
story you're reading if you go and read
a story during walt simonsen run that
features man
man gog and i can't remember the the
issues that it was featured in if you go
and you read that
that basically focuses on like man god
trying to take the odin sword and use it
to destroy
asgard it's one of these weapons that's
exceedingly powerful but it's not
immutable right like celestials have
destroyed versions of the odin sword
before but thor being given this weapon
is being done so
because as far as odin states it's the
only thing that can actually defeat the
serpent
that it's the only thing that can really
annihilate this thing you know basically
bring it to an end the other half of
this is remember
tony stark has been in asgard proper
working on creating asgardian tech or
really melding asgardian weapons with
uh stark tech in order to pass those
artifacts onto the avengers and so what
tony stark has basically done
is he's modified his own suit using
asgardian tech and then in turn created
a whole new
series of weapons so for the most part
like they're going into this battle
pretty heavy-handed the other half of
this is that with captain america
speaking to
really what's left of the avengers here
you basically got like wolverine you got
spider woman and so on and so forth it's
kind of interesting here because this is
really where captain america shines
right again there's really nothing
special about him but the fact that he's
been through
so much the fact that he's such an
incredible leader so on and so forth is
one of the reasons why so many
superheroes look up to him and so when
he sort of stands among the ranks of
really what's left and says
we have to keep fighting where some
people want to give up in the end they
don't you kind of have captain america
saying this is the last stand
if there's no one left here to fight
then this is the end of it and really
like the
dire nature of the situation is given
way when we end up seeing this instance
of captain america just brandishing a
shotgun this is really designed to be
like captain america among militiamen
captain america with a shotgun basically
looking like a poor man's leader facing
off against you know this
almost indestructible army of people
that are led by the serpent and so when
captain america basically brandishes
this shotgun
and goes to jump into the conflict what
this essentially means is that he
acknowledges the fact
they all marry and may very well die
here but in the middle of all this
suddenly the bifrost opens iron man
shows up alongside a whole bunch of
these other superheroes i guess really
the the various asgardians with the
weapons they've brought here now that's
kind of a cool thing
because what iron man does is dish them
out accordingly and then say look
these are going to create physical
changes in your body your body's going
to be modified to reflect the various
enchantments that have been put on here
by odin
you're gonna have a transformation akin
to thor and it works for what it is
because
each member of these uh really of of the
avengers wielding these weapons are able
to face off against like the heralds of
the serpent but not really the serpent
himself
that fight is really geared more toward
really really reserve more for
uh for thor himself and so it's kind of
an interesting thing because by and
large we would expect this to be a
battle that odin would fight odin is
usually hands off and the story does
really center around asgard and and thor
but when it comes to like odin engaging
in battle that only ever really happens
in like the most dire of situations only
if there's no
other choice left in this instance thor
the prophecy states
thor is supposed to fight the midgard
serpent and so that's what odin's
allowing to happen he's just kind of
going into this prophecy and calling it
a day now of course
thor throwing his hammer doesn't really
do anything and we never expected it to
and so where the hammer basically falls
back to earth it's left to odin i'm
sorry left to a thor to face off using
the odin sword and basically call it a
day but in this instance and it's one of
the coolest moments in the story
captain america refuses to quit and he
will not back down and so where he's
falling where the other avengers are
falling
left and right and all really seems to
be lost captain america
rallies the troops yet again and picks
up the hammer of thor now this
is the first real time that captain
america has picked up for his hammer
he's done it before and i can't remember
the exact issue i want to say it was it
was back during walt times run maybe
even before that but there was an
instance where captain america in a in a
moment of desperation had picked up
thor's hammer but it was really just
kind of like you know
like kind of swinging like swinging it
towards thor it wasn't really enough
where he could pick it up with one hand
and wield it but with captain america
wheeling the hammer of thor
the battle begins to shift because
seeing captain america do this
really like emboldens and heartens the
various avengers
even more because it means now we've
legitimately got a fighting chance
cap picked up thor's hammer holy that's
really kind of what that means here and
so
it's a really really cool moment because
turning the tide against the forces of
of of of the serpent basically means
that like the battle is essentially
coming to an end that it's really
beginning to to wind down here and so in
this massive conflict against the
midgard serpent some of the asgardians
end up riding into the scene are really
being led by odin to face off directly
against you know the the forces of the
serpent but the idea is that that
essentially thor is gonna die here which
he basically does he manages to
stab the serpent in the head using the
odin sword essentially killing him and
then in turn
falls to his own death and so it's kind
of a cool thing here because what this
does is it disperses the various hammers
of the serpent everybody returns back to
their normal state and then odin in turn
grabs thor and takes him back to asgard
now this is kind of a big moment here
because
the way that this was done all
indications was that this was going to
see the
the death of thor that thor was going to
be officially removed from the marvel
landscape that's the entire perspective
that was being put off by marvel the
issue with this
is that while thor is not the highest
selling character that marvel's ever had
he is certainly one of the most
recognizable
especially now in the marvel cinematic
universe and so when you're talking
about someone like thor you can't just
kill him off right i mean you can't just
get rid of him somebody has to take his
place
and so in this instance of course now
like well at least as awesome as it was
we had jane foster which
i'm still so pissed that she's not thor
anymore
but in this instance like thor would
have to return in some form or fashion
and so what this does is that in this
kind of rebuilding phase you know in
this moment when everything's sort of
being
the avengers are kind of rebuilding
everything and really a lot of the
work's being handed over to damage
control who in turn are going to start
rebuilding everything with their
government subsidies and contracts and
absolute corruption and the most heinous
of ways what this means
is that the serpent himself has kind of
been brought back to asgard and is going
to be monitored by odin but at the same
time thor is essentially like
burned at the pyre it's basically like
he's getting he's receiving an asgardian
funeral and so the question a lot of
people had is
what comes next like what comes after
this with thor being removed now
this is something that's kind of
interesting here so following this in
from 2010 going to 2011 and 2012
marvel launched marvel now and what
marvel now was designed to do was kind
of reshuffle things now this kicks off
something called
shattered heroes and shattered heroes
was basically the aftermath of fear
itself
and the fact that like the heroes had
basically been forced to face some of
their biggest fears and with the mar you
know as the marvel tagline always goes
and it changed the marvel universe
forever not really but that was that
that was the kind of tag line that was
basically being used but but in this
whole thing
what this did is it set the stage for
matt fraction to finish his run which
brings
in tanneris i'm pretty sure is how you
pronounce his name which is basically
ooh like the troll pretending to be
thor or pretending to be like a like a
thor reborn character and then loki
essentially rescuing the real thor by
kind of
splitting donald blake and thor at half
again so it was it was sort of like a
like a ham
fisted thing it's really what it was it
was it was kind of kind of like this
idea well
thorne and and donald blake are still
one person all right get rid of him like
get rid of that thing it's old hat
marvel's been doing it like we've been
doing it since 1960s just split them and
be done with it and that's basically
what it was and that leads directly into
jason aaron's
gore the god butcher story arc so you
got like six issues and then gore
that's that's really what happens here
it just kind of wraps up the tail bit of
thor
he eventually returns and that's that's
really the end of that but going into
shattered heroes things are actually
kind of cool to a degree it kind of
depends on what you're reading about if
you're reading like mighty avengers
things actually get pretty badass if
you're reading just like your standard
avengers well you know that basically
goes into hickman's avengers and new
avengers run and then you go into like
you know the the
you know the whole like basically
setting the stage for like avengers
versus x-men
and all that kind of good stuff uncanny
x-force i think continues on for a
little while there's a few things that
happen here and there of course
this also leads directly you know with
this whole situation between uh banner
and the hulk the hulk becoming a sort of
herald of the serpent uh this led into
the incredible hulk himself separating
bruce banner which we covered in jason
aaron's run so again
like a lot of the things that we've
covered recently within the last year or
so from like captain america and iron
man
and the incredible hulk and the avengers
and so on and so forth all that really
stems out of fear itself
all that really comes out of all this
stuff so again it's a pretty cool story
and it's pretty interesting in terms of
the purpose it serves but again it just
kind of sets the stage for things to
come after this but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah i
will catch you all later
peace
you